that's a blue this is new that's
open there we go we're gonna open yes
look see
i have two helpers do you know this is a
controller
that's a boom look at that
cosmic red oh we're already over it
have you played much playstation
recently okay you probably have it
okay which one do you like better so one
does not mean two
hold it up like this there you go no no
no don't stop recording
show them there you go can you say
cosmic red
can you say midnight night can you say
black monk
can you say sony honey can you say
playstation
taking them to dad are you playing the
game
i got to get close-up shots of it to
show the people just give me dads
okay bye